the imagination is the most marvelous
miraculous powerful force that the world
has ever known and Janome the average
individual uses the imagination if they
use it at all against themselves they
imagine what they don't want problems
coming you know you can use your
imagination to win to the future and
bring it into the present that's what
all highly successful people do
they see where they want to go and then
they act like the person they want to
become does the actors technique act
like the person you want to become how
do you did that but you use your
imagination
it's an inconceivable that would people
would wander around with so much power
and potential and squadron
see the average person literally tiptoes
through life hoping they make it saved
me to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way the average individual
really does not believe that they're
great
everyone's creative is just that some
have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others what do you want how do you
really want to live build the picture in
your mind the law of attraction is
always working it's the thoughts that
you're thinking that you impress upon
your subconscious mind that control the
vibration the bodies in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract you attract
energy that's in harmony with you you
attract people that are in harmony with
you you see everything operates on
frequencies there's an infinite number
of frequencies but you and I operate on
the frequency just like a radio station
does and the only music you can attract
is the music that is tuned into the
vibration you're in now it's the
paradigm that has been controlling the
vibration you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you really
change the paradigm and if you don't
change the paradigm nothing happens if
you keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem when we don't feel good we're in
a negative vibration we want to feel
good move into a positive vibration stop
and think of what you're grateful for
you will never attract wealth happiness
health until you get the paradigm get
you on that frequency you just watched
two amazing clips from Bob Procter take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]